-I'm also very excited about
the Stanley Cup semifinals.
They're in full swing right now.
Three teams remaining --
The Montreal Canadiens,
the Tampa Bay Lightning,
and the New York Islanders!
-Whoa.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now as you know, after the game,
they give out awards like
Most Valuable Player,
but they also give out awards
before the game.
You know that?
-No, I did not know that.
-Yeah, I'll show you
what I mean.
It's time for
"Tonight Show Superlatives."
Here we go.
-Oh.
-♪ Tonight Show Superlatives ♪
♪♪
-Our first player is from
the Islanders, Ilya Sorokin.
Yeah, he was voted "most likely
to kiss with his eyes open."
[ Laughter ]
-[ Smooching ]
-Next up from the Lightning
is Erik Cernak.
He was voted "most likely to be
Bart Simpson's DUI mugshot."
[ Laughter ]
Next up from the Lightning
is Victor Hedman.
-Oh, yeah.
-He was voted "most likely
to have just caused an 18-car
pile up with his mind."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-[ Imitates crash ]
-Next up from the Islanders
is Cory Schneider.
He was voted "most likely
to be the love child
of Blake Shelton and Barb
from 'Stranger Things.'"
-I didn't know
that was an award.
-What episode was that?
-A very specific award
to give out.
-It's rare. It's rare.
-Yeah.
-If that's what you mean.
Next, from Montreal,
is Jon Merrill.
[ Laughter ]
He was voted "most likely to
push you down a water slide."
It's like, "Alright, 3, 2 --
Go get 'em, man!"
[ Laughter ]
"You should have seen
your face, man!"
[ Laughter ]
Next up from Montreal
is Michael Frolik.
He was voted
"best mustache beard."
What does that mean?
Oh, there you go. Hey, not bad.
That's pretty cool.
-Yeah.
-That's cool, I like that.
Next up from the Islanders
is Simon Holmstrom.
He was voted "most likely
to have the nickname
'Swedish Larry Bird.'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Swedish accent ] "Yeah,
I throw the three-pointer."
-Yeah.
-[ Normal voice ]
Next up from the Lightning
is Anthony Cirelli.
He was voted "most likely
to turn in sharp 90-degree
angles when he walks."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Snare drum playing ]
And finally, from Montreal,
is Shea Weber.
He was voted "most likely
to sit down in a restaurant
and just tell the waiter,
'meat.'"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Those you are your Stanley Cup
semifinal superlatives.
Go, Islanders!